mit phosphat und hitze werden bei
sebastian liege fleischreste zu
kochschinken und wir machen jetzt mal
kochschinken so günstig wie es geht
und das ist alles regelkonform auch wenn
die metzgerin da verzweifelt
das ist das was im günstigen
kochschinken aus dem supermarkt steckt
zeigt euch sebastian liege
[Musik]
saftig und aus einem stück geschnitten
das macht einen leckeren kochschinken
aus metzger meisterin katharina koch
weiß was man dazu benötigt die keule vom
schwein
man kann auch ruhig pobacke sagen jetzt
auslösen und den koch schenken daraus
zubereiten wasser und pökelsalz bringt
die würze und farbe in den schinken mehr
braucht die metzgerin nicht zwei tage
bleibt die keule in der lage danach wird
er übrigens nicht gekocht wie der name
vermuten lässt
vielmehr wird der schinken für vier
stunden bei 65 grad schonend gegart
so wird er im zartesten
diesen leckerbissen möchte sich
sebastian liege natürlich nicht entgehen
lassen
vielen dank
aber auch viel zeit kostet auch sein
geld das stimmt bei katharina koch
kostet kochschinken gut zwei euro pro
100 gramm
sebastian hat einen anderen plan und wir
machen jetzt mal kochschinken so günstig
wie es geht
das heißt maschinen maschinen und auch
bei den zutaten hat sebastian die tricks
der industrie in küche ein großes
einzelstück braucht sebastian nicht er
setzt auf kleine fleischreste die stücke
dürfen nicht kleiner sein mit 250 gramm
weil sonst würden wir es nicht mehr
kochschinken nennen die vorschriften hat
sich die branche selber gegeben
also alles regelkonform sorry katharina
auch sebastian spritzt blut lag in das
fleisch allerdings deutlich mehr als die
metzgerin
und das bleibt nicht das einzige
hilfsmittel
in einer trommel werden die
fleischstücke mit ordentlich phosphat
vermischt
[Musik]
die chemikalie sorgt dafür dass die
reste gut aneinander kleben
aus vielen kleinen gesten bis zu in
schöner schicken so alle zaubertricks
sind vereint wird sorgen karussell
gleich los
[Musik]
nur zwölf stunden in der chemie trommel
und sebastians fleisch ist weich
katharinas schinken brauchte dafür
mehrere tage erreicht oder schreiben wir
aus schau mal rein was wir da so
fabriziert haben wirklich lecker
sebastian nun muss die fleischmasse nur
noch abgefüllt und gegart werden
dafür reicht ein plastikschlauch sie mit
dem ergebnis alle zufrieden dass wir
doch schon mal ganz gut aus
naja wenn er später auf geschnitten ist
und auf dem brötchen liegt und genau das
ist das problem
der trick funktioniert unterschiede im
fleisch sind wir uns fast nicht
erkennbar ob marke oder no nehmen die
hersteller müssen auf ihren verpackungen
nicht angeben wenn der kochschinken aus
mehreren teilen zusammengesetzt wurde
packt man den schinken auf dem
leuchttisch sind die einzelnen
fleischteile klar zu erkennen seid ihr
beim einkaufen ohne leuchttisch
unterwegs achtet auf die e-nummern 450
451 und 452 das sind phosphate denn die
verwendet muss die auch als zutat
kennzeichnen
und sebastian hat noch einen handfesten
tipp immer dem schwindel auch zu hause
auf die schliche kommt so liebe freunde
augen auf beim schinken kauf achte
darauf dass die fasern gleichmäßig
laufen und nicht wie navigationssystem
nach links und rechts zeigen dann ist er
nur zusammen gewürfelt qualität kostet
dann schmeckt auch noch mehr tricks
checks und duelle aus der welt der
lebensmittel findet ihr auf unserem
kanal zdf besser esser